[MUSIC PLAYING]
SANDEEP DINESH: I'm a developer
advocate here at Google.
Normally I do crazy live
demos, but unfortunately you
won't see that today.
Instead I want to go through
some really cool features
that we have at GKE that
I think a lot of people
in the documentation
gets lost somewhere
and they just don't
know it's available.
So before I get
started, I do want
to let you know that
there's a Dory available.
Dory is how we ask
questions internally
at Google during presentations.
And so you can go in your app
and do that Dory Q&A thing
and you can ask questions
by just typing them in.
So GKE or Google Kubernetes
Engine, how many people
are familiar with this?
Most people?
Yep.
So GKE is basically Google's
managed Kubernetes offering.
What is Kubernetes Engine?
Basically it's a
one-click solution
that lets you deploy your
master and your nodes,
create those, permission
those for you,
and give you access
to them, right?
And so you can
access that master,
it's kind of hidden
away from you,
you don't have to
worry about it.
We take care of upgrading
it and patching it and doing
all that good stuff.
And at Google, of course,
we've been doing containers
for a really long time.
Most of you have probably
seen a slide similar to this.
We launched cgroups, and open
sourced it way back in 2006;
Kubernetes was open
sourced in 2014;
and then GKE went generally
available, 1.0, in 2015.
But so what?
Everyone is doing
Kubernetes now, right?
Everyone-- all the cloud
providers have Kubernetes.
Random mom and pop down
the street has Kubernetes.
As long as you pass
the conformance tests,
you have a Kubernetes, right?
So what?
Why is Google different?
I really think that there's
fundamental things that
need to be done around
Kubernetes to make it useful,
right?
Just having Kubernetes
by itself is great,
but it can be a lot harder
to use than it needs to be.
And so there's three
major areas where
I think you need support
around, and a platform that's
built around Kubernetes
to really make
a good big difference, right?
So what is infrastructure?
And then we have
networking and security,
and tooling and automation.
So let's talk about
infrastructure to start.
So these are things we
take for granted every day.
So cluster creation.
Yeah, it's literally
just one command,
and you get your master
and your nodes, right?
gcloud container clusters
create, give it a name,
and boom, you're
off to the races.
Other people might make
this a little harder.
If you're doing it yourself, you
know how hard it is sometimes
to set up Kubernetes manually.
With GKE, one command
and we're good to go.
Pretty straightforward stuff,
everyone here should know this.
But just-- something
to remember about-- we
take for granted every day.
Speaking of nodes that
are automatically created,
they're actually automatically
updated and repaired.
So a lot of providers might
update their master version
automatically, but then
leave node management to you.
We kind of believe that
the whole thing needs
to work together, and so
we actually automatically
can update and repair your node.
So if you go from
1.12 to 1.13, we
can actually-- as your
master version gets updated,
we can update your node
version for you automatically.
And if something goes
wrong with the node-- let's
say the Docker daemon dies,
the kubelet, something
goes wrong with it, we can do
that-- we can automatically
detect that with the health
check, delete that node,
and spin up a new
one automatically
to take its place.
Again, you don't
have to do anything,
you don't have to worry about
the actual infrastructure
anymore.
So another really cool feature
of GCE is node customization.
So you can make something
called custom VMs with a custom
amount of CPU, memory, throw
on the local SSDs, GPUs,
things like that, and you get
all that same capabilities
in GKE.
What this means is
you're not limited
to certain types of machines
that can run on GKE.
Any GCE VM can also run on GKE.
And this gives you a
lot more flexibility.
If you need a beefy node
to do some sort of workload
and you need a really small
node to do something else,
you can have that mix and
match of capabilities.
If you need GPUs like a P100
or V100 or whatever, easier
to add onto your GKE cluster.
And speaking of
picking the right size,
GCE actually has a machine
learning algorithm built into--
do something called cluster node
right sizing recommendations.
So here we can actually look
at your utilization of your VMs
and say, hey, you're
overutilizing your VMs.
You should probably pump
up the RAM a little bit
so you can get some more
smoother performance,
or this machine is way too
big, you're wasting money.
Downsize it, save a bunch
of money on your bill.
And again, because
it's built on GCE,
all these features
pipe directly into GKE.
Now one of my favorite, favorite
things is preemptible nodes.
And I don't think people use
these nearly enough to take
advantage of them.
So I actually did a three-month
data collection experiment
where I ran an app that
was constantly paying
and I wrote a bunch of data and
I did a bunch of data analysis,
and I found out that
you can basically
run three times your
capacity for the same cost
and get almost no
detectable baseline
like difference, right?
So if you had one
node for $10 and you
had three nodes now for $10,
yes, those preemptible nodes
can die, they get
preempted every 24 hours,
they might get shut down, but
it happens at such an irregular
basis and it happens--
and Kubernetes
is so resilient, I'm
spinning up the containers
to take its place,
that if you're
running stateless
workloads and you're not
using preemptible VMs,
you are definitely
leaving money on the table.
I wrote a whole blog post about
this where I go into detail.
Ooh, animations.
So of course, I talked
about how you can kind
mix and match those different
types of VMs together.
And so the way we do that in GKE
is something called node pools.
And so again, something
that I don't think people
take advantage of, most people
make a Kubernetes cluster
and they have one type of node.
You can actually take
different types of nodes,
give them different
labels and tags,
and then run different
workloads on those.
So your database can
go on a more CPU-heavy,
memory-heavy node;
your stateless web app
can go on the smaller
nodes that are cheaper;
your machine learning workloads
can go on your GPU nodes;
and you can have them all
in the same cluster, which
makes networking and all that
kind of stuff a lot easier
to setup.
And another big feature that
we rolled out about last year
is regional clusters.
So by default, clusters are
created in a single zone,
right?
The problem with that
is-- there's twofold.
One, if that zone goes down,
well then you're out of luck.
And two, during
a master upgrade,
the cluster might still
work, but the API server
goes down, right?
So you can't give it updates
and things like that.
But the regional
cluster, we actually
spread those nodes over
three different zones
in the same region.
And so this gives you one,
higher availability, right?
If a zone goes down,
you're still good,
you still have these two other
zones that are up and running.
And two, higher master
availability because you
have highly available masters.
Because we have three different
masters, one in each zone.
When we do an upgrade, we
actually do it one at a time
so we never lose access to
your Kubernetes API server.
Really cool stuff.
And if you're using
regional clusters,
you can use regional
persistent disks.
Now these are
really, really cool.
So basically it
creates two disks,
and one is a clone of the other.
And any write that's
sent to the first disk
is just forked at
our network level
to both disks the same time.
So any writes that go in are
actually written to both disks
simultaneously with no
performance downgrade, right?
And so what happens
if zone A goes down,
zone B becomes hot and
starts serving data,
and there's no real disruption
to the end application.
This is actually how
Cloud SQL for Postgres
runs under the covers.
It uses these regional
persistent disks
to provide high availability.
And because GKE has native
built-in connections
to all of the stuff, you
can use it as well in GKE.
Now another important
thing is autoscaling.
And so everyone can do
autoscaling based on CPU.
Pretty trivial, but with
Stackdriver and with GKE,
you can autoscale
on custom metrics.
So anything your app needs,
like number of incoming requests
or a number of
open file handlers,
whatever you need
to scale your app,
you can send that to Stackdriver
and scale your GKE nodes
based on those metrics.
And speaking of
autoscaling, GKE provides
something called
vertical pod autoscaling.
Now how many people are
familiar with horizontal pod
autoscaling?
Most people.
So horizontal pod autoscaling
is pretty straightforward.
You run out of CPU, you
spin up another pod,
you spin up another pod,
it spins out horizontally.
But vertical pod
autoscaling can actually
set your memory
requests per container
and actually make it
them go bigger or smaller
depending on the workload.
We actually again
use machine learning
to figure out how much
memory your container needs.
So if it needs more, we'll
actually make-- redeploy
those pods with more requests,
and if they need less,
we'll spin them down with less.
So we're actually
spinning the pod requests
up and down for
you automatically.
So we can do both vertical pod
autoscaling, horizontal pod
autoscaling, as well
as cluster autoscaling.
So it's like multiple dimensions
of autoscaling all at once,
and we optimize that all for
you, which is really cool.
Ooh, look at that.
And of course today we
announce Anthos, GKE On-Prem.
So we can do all this really
cool GKE stuff or most of it
not only on our cloud, but
on-prem and in other providers
as well.
So that's really
cool, and there's
other talks that can go
more into detail on that.
So I talked about
the infrastructure,
and now I want to really
get into the bread
and butter of where I think
GCP shines, especially
in terms of GKE.
So when you go from a monolith
or a VM-based architecture,
a lot of the networking
assumptions you make change
dramatically when you moved to
containers and microservices,
right?
The networking gets
way more complex,
and if you're not built
from the ground up
to support that kind of stuff,
things can fall apart, right?
The old paradigms
kind of fall apart.
So let's talk about
networking first.
So normally you have your
nodes and you have pods
on those nodes.
And so these nodes are VMs,
and they have IP addresses
on the VPC, right?
But those pods, the
IP addresses that they
have are virtual
IPs that are only
routable within the cluster.
So the problem here is that when
you want to send a request out,
those IP addresses
get masked with NAT,
and so the node IP address
goes out, not the actual pods.
So you don't really know
which pod on that node
is making that request.
And the same thing coming in,
you don't-- it's really hard
to route traffic to a pod on
the node because you have to go
through the node first.
But with IP aliasing
or VPC native pod IPs,
those pods actually get
real GCP IP addresses
that are natively
routable on the VPC.
So what does this let you do?
It lets you do
really cool things
like container-native
load balancing.
So in the old world, you
spin up a load balancer.
That load balancer has no
idea what's running inside
of those VMs, right?
It just knows-- send
traffic to that pod--
sorry, to that VM on this
port, and then IP tables inside
of that node has to do another
routing to the actual pod,
right?
And that pod might not even
be running on the same VM.
We call it a double-hop problem.
So it might go to
one virtual machine
and then get routed to
another virtual machine,
and then go to the pod, right?
Lot of hops, a lot
of latency that's
added to your infrastructure.
With container-native
load balancing,
our load balancers actually
know the physical IP addresses--
well, not physical, everything's
virtual these days--
but the actual IP
address of the pod itself
and can route traffic
directly into that pod
without going through IP tables,
without going through NATing,
without any of that stuff.
So you get a lot less
latency, and more importantly,
you get more transparency.
You don't have to go
through your logs.
If you go through your VPC
flow logs and like, OK, well
it went from this VM to that
VM and then to that container.
Instead it's just from that
load balancer, that container,
straight line, right?
Much easier to reason with
and debug and analyze.
And speaking of
load balancing, we
have internal load
balancing as well.
And so this, again, it's
straight built into Kubernetes,
so we can provision an internal
load balancer the same way
as an external load balancer.
And so this lets you expose
your Kubernetes services
to non-Kubernetes
services inside GKE--
inside Google Cloud, right?
So if you have a service running
on VMs, a traditional kind
of thing that you haven't
migrated to GKE yet,
you can just expose
your GKE service,
and it gives you an
IP address that's
routable inside of the VPC.
And the really nice
thing is because this
is done with an SDN,
there's no overhead,
and everything's
just done-- there's
no box sitting there, right?
We just know where
to send the traffic.
And the other way around--
Cloud NAT.
So if you have a
third-party service that
requires a whitelist
of IPs, well, it's
kind of hard to do with GKE.
Those nodes come and
go, the IP addresses
change, you might
spin up your cluster
to make it bigger
or smaller, so how
do you give them a
whitelist of IPs?
Well with Cloud NAT, you can
actually create an IP address,
and all the traffic gets
routed through that IP address.
So it looks like all the traffic
is coming from a single IP
address, but it's scalable
because again, we're
doing SDN magic under
the covers to make
it look like the traffic
is coming from this IP.
So you just give that IP
to your third party person,
they whitelist it,
and you're good to go.
You don't have to worry
about managing a list of IPs
and things like that.
And then we have
multi-cluster ingress.
So this is really cool.
We have a bunch of
clusters around the world.
You can spin up a single load
balancer with a single IP
address, and it can route
traffic to all of your clusters
automatically, right?
So we'll actually find
the closest cluster
to the user using anycast,
and we can route their traffic
to that cluster without
you having to do
DNS or anything complicated.
And I actually have a talk a few
years ago at Next where I spun
up a multi-cluster ingress
using [? Ku ?] [? Federation, ?]
which is quite a while ago.
So if you want to check
that out, check it out.
And then we have
deep integration
with other networking products
like CDN, IAP, and Cloud Armor.
So Cloud CDN, as the
name implies, is our CDN.
Really powerful stuff.
IAP, Identity-Aware Proxy, lets
you throw this little proxy
in front of our load balancer
that-- we call it BeyondCorp,
you can read the paper.
Basically like you don't
have to build security--
if your application requires
something like a VPN
to connect to it, right?
If you're using
VPN for security,
there's an alternative where
you don't have to use a VPN.
Instead, you can use
OAuth to authenticate you
as an end user, and then
log in to that service.
So for your
application, it still
looks like it's in the
VPN, but this proxy kind of
lets you do that without
VPNs, which is really nice.
And then Cloud Armor, which
is our anti-DDoS protection.
And they're not
just built add-ons.
These are-- you can actually
configure all these things
with Kubernetes-native
objects, which is really cool.
All right, so security.
Security is really important,
especially in Kubernetes land.
How many people saw the Tesla
like cryptomining thing?
Yeah.
So their cluster got
hacked and people started
running crypto stuff on it.
And so what I'm going
to talk about now
is kind of layers of security
that we add to make it more
harder for an attacker to
get into your systems, right?
So the first thing
is private clusters
and master authorized networks.
Private clusters, it's
literally what the name implies.
The cluster doesn't
have public IPs,
therefore it's only
internal, right?
And again, master
authorized networks,
only certain people can
log into the master,
not some random person on
the internet cannot, like,
SSH into your master, right?
So again, just another
layer of protection.
So if they break
into your network,
then yeah, they still
could log into your master,
so how do we get around that?
So we have something
called network policy.
Network policy in
GKE, we automatically
install something called
Calico into your cluster
to make sure that when you
set these network policies,
they're enforced.
And so these are
really powerful stuff.
You can say, this namespace can
talk to this namespace, but not
the other way around.
Or these pods can
talk to these pods,
but they can't talk
to any other pods.
And so my co-worker Ahmet
has a really good blog post
and a GitHub repo that goes
through all these namespace--
sorry, these network
policies and how they work.
Highly recommend
checking it out,
it's where I stole
this picture from.
But I guess you get another
layer of control, right?
So someone is able to
break into the app-web,
they can talk to any
containers but the containers
can't talk back, right?
So you get a little bit more
control over what's going on.
Kubernetes secrets.
So for the longest
time, Kubernetes secrets
were not encrypted.
In more recent versions of
Kubernetes they are encrypted,
and with GKE, you can actually
encrypt them with Cloud KMS,
and so you can manage
those encryption keys
and rotate them
and do everything
that you can with Cloud KMS,
now for your Kubernetes-native
secrets.
Again, just making it
easier to use, right?
And then binary
authorization, this
is a really cool new feature.
Basically, let's say someone
does break into your Kubernetes
cluster, and now they want
to run cryptomine.latest
or something like that.
Well, they can't, because
it's not authorized.
So we can actually enforce
signed containers--
so only containers
that are signed by you
can actually even run
on your cluster, right?
So again, rogue developer
who wants to run something
can't do it, it
has to be signed.
So this is really powerful.
Again, locking down another
layer of security that we
give you in GKE.
Now how many people
know about this?
Container registry
vulnerability scanning?
A few people.
Yeah, so this is really cool.
If you're using
Alpine or Ubuntu,
it actually automatically scans
your containers for known CVEs
and it'll surface those for you.
So you can see, I uploaded
some really old containers
and have tons of
issues, as expected.
And you can go
through and see what's
important to you, what
you should update,
and things like that.
Usually if you're building
containers fairly regularly,
they should be
fairly up to date,
but this is a good
way to see like, oh, I
have an old container with
a bunch of vulnerabilities,
let me update it, or hey,
this new vulnerability
came out, let me make sure that
I'm not being affected, right?
So really cool stuff, and
again, built straight into GCR.
So the last section,
monitoring and tools.
So here are things again I
think people forget about,
or they're just kind
of, heh, it's there.
I don't remember.
But when you don't
have it, you're like,
I really wish I did.
So one is Stackdriver
Kubernetes Monitoring.
There are quite a few tools
nowadays to monitor Kubernetes.
Stackdriver has been updated to
monitor not just the VMs that
are running your
cluster, but actually
your pods and your services
that are internally, right?
So here we can see that--
we can't see anything
because that's like a
super blurry picture,
but if you could see that
picture, you would actually
see the nodes, the pods in those
nodes, how much memory they
have, they're healthy, all the
custom metrics that you set all
on one pane of glass,
which is really nice.
CI/CD is necessary.
Cloud Build is one
way of doing that.
And I think Cloud Build is a
really easy lightweight CI/CD
tool that you can
use, especially for--
if you don't have
anything too complicated,
you just put your steps
in, it runs those commands,
and it can build your
container for you.
And you can do more
complicated stuff
like actually deploy a
Kubernetes, run health checks,
do all this kind of stuff.
It's a very, very
simplistic product,
but it really has
a lot of power.
And because it's
completely serverless,
you don't have to worry about
provisioning a CI/CD like Build
pipeline or anything like that.
You literally just run a job
and it just runs it for you,
and you get tons of
free Build minutes
per day, which is really cool.
Now this one.
It's something that most people,
again, don't really think
is a differentiator, but the GKE
Dashboard is really powerful.
You can see your workloads,
you can see your services,
you can drill really
deep into these things.
There's a really nice GUI.
You can edit them
right from there.
You can create new deployments,
you can look at the status,
you can do all
this kind of stuff,
again, without writing
a single line of code
or going into single
command line, right?
Right from that
pantheon dashboard
you can see everything that
you need, which is really nice.
The Service Broker.
This one is really useful if you
want your Kubernetes operators
to be able to provision
other GCP services
or, for that matter,
open-source services or even
other cloud services directly
from GKE objects, right?
So you can say, hey, spin up
a Cloud Firestore database,
and it'll just spin
that up for you
and give you those credentials
back as native GKE secrets.
Really, really powerful, and it
gives you a better integration
into the rest of
both Google Cloud
and open-source ecosystem.
And finally, I'm going to
talk about namespace and label
resource usage.
So how many people
here have a GKE cluster
that is shared between teams?
A few people.
So a really cool thing
is you can actually
export usage based on
namespaces and based on labels.
So let's say that you
have namespace X that's
used by team 1.
You can actually see
how much of the cluster
that they use
versus namespace C.
And the same for your apps.
So if you have two
apps labeled app A
and they're in
different namespaces,
you can, again, get that
export of the resource usage
for those apps
outside of the place.
So really cool stuff,
especially if you
have multiple teams
using the same cluster
and you want to break that
down for analytics purposes.
So we have to add-ons that I
want to talk about, because I
think they're really powerful.
So one is the GKE Istio add-on.
You click one button when
you're creating a cluster
and you get Istio installed
into your cluster for you
automatically.
Really cool stuff.
If you don't know
what Istio is, I'm
sure there's some
talks around here
that you could
probably wander into,
but long story short, it's
called a service mesh,
and it really adds
a lot of value
to you if you're doing
microservices architecture
on GKE.
It adds a lot of value for
you automatically without you
having to do too much work.
If you don't what Istio is, go
look it up, it's pretty cool.
And then we have Cloud
Run on GKE as well.
And so this built on
top of Istio and Knative
to be able to run serverless
workloads on top of GKE.
So it's the same Cloud Run APIs
that you can run serverlessly
on GCP.
You can actually run it
inside of a Kubernetes cluster
as well.
So you get the same
developer experience end
to end no matter
if you're running
on our serverless platform or
on our Kubernetes platform.
But don't take my word for it.
With me, I have
Brad from Symphony.
Symphony Communications.
He's a VP of
Architecture here, and I
want to give him
the floor to kind
of talk about his
GKE experience,
and here you go, yeah.
BRAD DIETRICH: Thanks, Sandeep.
And so as many of
you, we kind of
embarked on the Kubernetes
path a while ago
looking at the ability to
containerize an application.
The application,
of course, has been
around for longer than
what we actually wanted
to do with containerization.
We were doing a lot of the heavy
lifting that Sandeep described.
We were running
virtual machines,
we were maintaining
those virtual machines,
operating systems up, and trying
to keep a secure platform.
What Symphony
actually is is it's
a secure team
collaboration platform,
but it is really focused on
financial services customers
as our primary business segment.
And if you've ever worked
with those customers,
you know that they are
extremely sensitive to security.
So security was always kind at
the core of everything we do.
And we've worked for a couple
of years now with the GKE team
specifically around crafting
the security messages
that you heard from Sandeep.
Working with product
managers, telling
them what was important for
us and our customer base
so that it becomes
more accessible
across the entire industry.
Not just something that
you can actually focus on
from an internet-based
application, but actually
something that individual banks
and large financial services
institutions would
start to trust as well.
And that's really,
again, what Symphony is
and where we see a
lot of value and a lot
of continued innovation.
And in trying to drive
that security, things
like the private GKE clusters,
the ability to actually know
that banks still think about
how we're going to actually get
into our networks, make sure
that everything is signed,
signed images are
going to be very
important from our
perspective as well.
So that we can actually
have high confidence
that the cluster is only
running what we want it to run,
and the individual teams
within both our organization
and our customers'
organizations have
good visibility and good
auditability around what that's
running and where those
individual pieces are
able to talk to each other.
SANDEEP DINESH: Cool.
So Brad, I have some
canned questions for you.
BRAD DIETRICH: Sure.
SANDEEP DINESH: And then
we'll open up the floor
to questions from the audience.
Again, remember the
Dory is available
if you want to just
type it in if you don't
want to come up to the mic.
So when you chose
GKE as your platform,
what was like one of the
biggest challenges moving from--
again, you said like a
VM-based architecture
to that container-based
architecture?
BRAD DIETRICH: Sure.
So we actually are dual-hosted.
We've been hosted in AWS
and GCP for a long time.
We had been on both
in the VM world,
but we treated our VMs very
much like you would consider
an internal data center.
And in fact, part
of our architecture
does include our customers'
data centers as well, that's
one of the reasons that we
can actually have the security
model that we have.
So we've always
been looking at ways
to optimize the efficiencies
around how do we
administer AWS, GCP, and
our customers' data centers.
And that's really where
Kubernetes and containerization
shines.
It gives us the ability to
package our application in ways
that we can deliver to
our customers on-premise.
They do it in GKE
On-Prem in some cases,
but they do it in Cloud
Foundry or other things that
are container-based
orchestration systems.
We build our containers
for our cloud system
to really kind of evolve
the platform there.
And it was some heavy lifting.
I mean, many of you have
probably been through it.
The assumptions around VM,
some of the things Sandeep
already mentioned, they
have to be rethought,
and the architecture
has to be evolved.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, so
speaking of re-architecting, so
has Kubernetes and
GKE kind of forced
you to re-architect
or reconsider
some design decisions that
you've made in the past?
BRAD DIETRICH: It is,
but I mean, part of it
is-- you mentioned
monolith earlier,
and our original application,
like most as early startups
get started, tends to be
a little bit monolithic.
And so that's really what
we're looking at right now,
is how do we break the
monolith in such a way
to gain resiliency, gain scale
with the right layers that
make sense.
Allow teams to operate-- because
we have 153 engineers depending
on how you count the
external help that we have--
that are driving in parallel.
And as you guys
know, trying to get
everybody aligned and everybody
headed in the same direction
is really difficult,
and microservices can
make a big difference there.
We're still breaking apart
the monolith to some extent,
but that's the evolution
path that many of you are on,
and that's where
we're on as well.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, so what
would you say the biggest
challenge in breaking--
or decomposing,
let's say that, it's a
nice word-- in decomposing
your monolith, right?
So it's a really long
journey, as you mentioned.
What's kind of been the hardest
part, and then how has GKE
kind of helped you do that?
BRAD DIETRICH: Sure.
Yeah.
So I mean, the nice thing
about GKE is the ease of access
that Sandeep already
mentioned-- spin up
a cluster with one command.
We've had kind of our engineers
that we've been training--
Google actually offers a bunch
of training support, too.
Our TMs have come in and brought
in individuals that show us
and our teams how to use
Kubernetes the right way,
the best practices way so we can
actually evolve the thinking.
The hardest part in my
opinion of how to do this
is rarely the technical part.
The technical part,
a couple people
can sit around a whiteboard
and break up the thing
and decide the right
way to break it up,
the right contracts to
make sure the services
talk to each other.
But if the engineering
team-- if the talent that you
have don't understand
the tools well enough
or don't understand the
methodologies you're
trying to achieve, that's where
you can get a lot of advantage
just by the
accessibility of GKE.
There's no reason
that we should have
to spin our own Kubernetes
cluster to learn Kubernetes
with GKE.
SANDEEP DINESH: OK.
And so final question.
What are-- and this is
two questions in one.
What's the most exciting
thing about GKE for you?
Or the future of GKE.
Like what's the
most exciting thing
that you see on the roadmap
that you're excited about maybe
that's public?
And then more personally, what
do you guys are building inside
of Symphony that you
really want to talk about
and are super excited about?
BRAD DIETRICH: Well,
I can't talk too much
about the latter one.
Again, we--
SANDEEP DINESH: I tried.
BRAD DIETRICH: We are
doing a bunch of things
around workflow automation.
You see these things happening,
you see autonomous agents
happening in the industry.
We are a tool very similar
to Slack or Microsoft Teams,
although we're focused
much more on the security
and the compliance aspects.
But all those same
things that you
see happening on those tools,
even things like chat ops
that you guys are probably
already doing in your teams,
are just as relevant
for our customers
and our financial
services industry.
And so we really
see a lot of value
about bringing
containerization to those tools
that our customers
are building as well.
And one of the pieces--
you mentioned GKE On-Prem.
One of the pieces that
is still difficult for us
and our customers is
that on-prem piece.
We'll never get rid of it.
it's part of our architecture,
it's a key part of
our architecture.
We also won't be administering
our own on-prem clusters
because they're our
customers' data centers.
But they may opt to use
more and more of GKE On-Prem
to really kind of aid themselves
in making that an easier
tool for them to use.
But our customers are
also, like I said,
very security conscious.
And so we have to
understand that some
of the kind of cloud-managed
on-prem infrastructure for them
is something that they have
to kind of work through
and understand the
security implications of.
They're really uncomfortable
with things reaching
from the cloud back in.
They have very constricted
firewalls and border security
in a lot of their data centers.
So it's something to
consider, and as GKE evolves,
certainly there's
kind of an air gap
notion of potentially how
we might view and administer
a cluster without actually
having direct access to it.
SANDEEP DINESH: Cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]